what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have
our very first promo art images of
spider-man
no way home and before you ask yes these
are
official these were listed on amazon for
spider-man no way home merchandise it
looks like they're about to roll out
a lot for spider-man no way home in
terms of promotion
which is very good news for all of us
who are waiting for that trailer
and i think everybody is going to really
like these images that we're about to
talk about
the images for all of these t-shirts and
other merchandise that is about to come
out there actually are
kind of revealing about a few things in
the movie including
teasing mysterio and actually giving us
a really really good look at
spider-man's new suits
well we have about 20 different promos
that were released
so let's dive into it but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
spider-man videos
so to start off there's actually a
pretty big emphasis
on dr strange obviously we knew that he
was going to be in the movie but
this merchandise puts a lot of emphasis
on his part
and it's looking like there is going to
be a lot of magic
being used in spiderman no way home not
just from doctor strange but from
spiderman
as well it looks like the rumors and
plot leaks were true doctor strange is
going to give
some of his magic to spider-man either
with an enchantment or something else
and magically charge his suits so tom
holland spider-man is going to get a
pretty big upgrade in no way home
so to start off some of these promo
images are just of doctor strange
him by himself him with spider-man and
his new black and gold magical suit
a picture that is half his face half
spider-man's face but then we have a
picture that is of doctor strange and
spider-man in his black and red suit
coming out of a portal
now some people may just think that
doctor strange is using one of these
portals to teleport him and peter to
somewhere else in new york
but for those of us who have been
keeping up with everything we know that
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man are going to be in
this film and it is going to be a
spider-verse
slash multiverse film and even if you
don't believe toby maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man are going
to be in the film we know that out for
molina's doc
ock and jamie foxx's electro are going
to be in the film that is confirmed they
both confirmed this
themselves and the marvel studios
president kevin feige basically
confirmed that himself too because he
was kind of making fun of
trying to keep everything a secret
somebody asked him a question about it
and he said why don't you ask alfred
molina in a jokingly way
implying that he kind of gave it all
away which he did so we love him for
that
but this image of spider-man and doctor
strange
coming out of a portal is very very
interesting because my question is where
are they going
or where are they coming from i
personally would like to believe that
this
is a multiversal portal the title is
called no way home so perhaps doctor
strange and peter do
end up in a different universe however i
do think the title is more than likely
referring to
the other spider-man and the villains
not being able to go home to their
original universe
now perhaps one of the coolest images
that we got yesterday
is of spider-man in his black and gold
suit that seems to be enchanted with
magic
again obviously dodger strange is going
to grant him a little bit of magic or
enchant one of his suits
and as we can see here it actually looks
pretty dang cool he's shooting his webs
out and his webs actually seem to be
enchanted by magic as well we can see
the mystic rings and ruins behind him we
can also see it around the webs that
he's shooting
this is going to be a spider-man like
we've never seen before
we've never seen on screen a spider-man
use magic we've
never seen a magical integrated
spider-man suit
we also have another similar photo of
spider-man using magic on the front of a
shirt it says magic
with a thwip and as we can see here it
is the black and gold suit that we've
seen and that i'll talk about a little
bit more but it kind of looks like it
has some blue in this photo
perhaps when he uses magic it kind of
changes colors because there is no doubt
that that is part of the complete
black and gold suit but the magic could
make it change colors if we had any
doubt about the magic before
this shirt literally says magic with a
thwhip and of course that is referring
to him
thwipping slinging his webslingers which
again are also going to be enchanted so
perhaps he'll have more control over
them perhaps they'll be stronger perhaps
they can actually
do different things we're not 100 sure
at this point but i
am definitely excited to see it on
screen and speaking of that black and
gold suit we do have a full look
at the black and gold suit here
spider-man is actually holding on to a
web
and we see the full entire suit and they
put an emphasis
on the logo on his chest in the bottom
right now the logo kind of looks like
the iron spider-man logo except the legs
aren't nearly as big
and the logo overall seems to be a
little bit smaller but perhaps the
emblem
actually does something perhaps it
becomes a drone or holds some magical
capabilities
now it also does show the iron spider
suit and based off of all of the leaks
that we've seen so far
we know that peter parker is indeed
going to get the iron spider
suit back however it looks like he's
also going to be changing it just a
little bit
and in one of these promotional images
it actually looks like kind of
blue prince for his iron spider suit and
it says
integrated iron spider suit plus red and
black suit
and we've also had leaks for a so-called
integrated suit which we assumed was
going to be integrated with
magic but perhaps it being integrated
simply means it is one suit mixed or
integrated with
another suit however i do have a theory
if we take a look again
at the magic with the thwhip photo it
kind of does
look like peter is wearing a combination
of two different suits
it kind of looks like he fused or
integrated the black and gold suit on
top of the iron spider suit because it's
very clear that we can see
some red and blue in this suit so
perhaps in the movie spider-man gets
this
original magical black and gold suit but
then perhaps down the road he needs some
upgraded armor and technology
so he fuses or integrates the iron
spider suit with the new
magical suit i'm gonna take a shot and
say that's what's gonna happen
now besides all of the new magical suits
we actually have some pictures and
promos
for what i'm going to call the more
grounded part of spiderman no way home
no magical suits no multiverse no
portals
but things that actually pick up from
where spiderman no way home
left off we have a few different designs
that say
we believe mysterio now as huge
as this film is going to be we can't
forget that it
is picking up right where spider-man far
from home left off
mysterio framed peter parker and
everybody thinks that spider-man is a
murderer and they do
know that peter is spider-man and it
looks like there's going to be somewhat
of a division
between people who believe what mysterio
said and people who believe
peter parker spider-man as we have a
promo image that says
you rock peter parker and it shows a
spider-man hand
and this kind of leads me to believe
that peter parker is indeed going to go
to trial
after all charlie cox's matt murdock is
heavily rumored and reported to be in
this film as peter parker's lawyer so
they'll probably go to court and peter
will probably state his case that
mysterio
framed him he made everything up and of
course this is going to get out to the
public and
it's going to be divided some people are
going to believe mysterio because of the
video
but some people are going to be
spider-man fans and they're going to
realize that he fought with the avengers
in avengers infinity war and avengers
in-game he literally died in infinity
war but he was trying to be an avenger
he was trying to help and ultimately he
did help save the entire
universe and the people that realize
this are going to think that no he's not
a bad guy he's a good guy he's an
avenger mysterio is lying
so on top of everything you know
multiversal threats and villains popping
up
he still has to deal with what mysterio
set him up for at the end of spider-man
far from home but this is super exciting
because these are the first
promotional official promotional images
that we've gotten from spider-man no way
home
hopefully this means that the trailer
isn't that far away because you can't
really start to promo a movie
that nobody knows about the general
public doesn't really know about this
movie because they're not sitting on the
internet every day like we are so if
you're going to start promoting a film
you need the trailer to come out so
hopefully that means it's coming pretty
soon
and of course as always if i hear
anything i'll be sure to update
everybody
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
don't forget to let me know what you
think about it in the comments down
below don't forget to give the video a
like and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you